primeramente muchas gracias por la
entrevista y
pues yo quisiera compartir mi
experiencia que seguramente es la
experiencia de muchos hombres y mujeres
del mundo que retoman su propio poder
para saber que cada uno de nosotros y
nosotras podemos ser sanadores de
nuestra propia existencia de nuestro
propio camino la salud es un derecho
universal para todos incluidos los
pueblos originarios dado eso no es
todavía un como una parte que sea
sustancial para nuestros pueblos en
nuestros pueblos originarios y no hablo
sólo de los pueblos del que yo soy parte
que soy zapoteca sino hablo de todos los
pueblos del mundo no esté
y eso debería estar cubierto como tal
pero como no hay médico entonces ahí si
son validados los conocimientos que uno
trae por ejemplo cuando atiendo parto es
validado siempre y cuando esté en mi
comunidad y lo baje y lo remita al
médico aunque el nombre que aparezca es
el del médico y no el de la partera que
trajo al mundo y la salud es una cosa y
la sanidad es otra cosa y la sanación
colectiva la forma de cómo nos miramos a
nosotros mismos para sanar que no
depositamos solo en la salud como un
sistema nuestra responsabilidad de estar
bien plus porque lo que buscamos es
estar bien estar bien con tu corazón con
tu paz interna con tu equilibrio que le
dice muchas gracias a las plantas muchas
gracias a este día al amanecer muchas
gracias a la sagrada naturaleza que nos
está dando pues este té para tomar
los animales que están ladrando los
gallos que están sonando no todos los
pajaritos que están sonando es eso cómo
me veo yo como una parte de todo el
entorno y entonces ahí agradezco eso en
lugar de quedarme con el dolor de si
mirar que algo no está caminando bien la
salud universal como tal es un derecho
para todos y todas y todos no personas
ser humano que evite cualquier parte del
territorio porque es parte de los
derechos universales de todos y todas y
todos
la sanación
viene siendo como un proceso de decisión
personal es hacernos cargo de nuestro
propio cuerpo
desde habitar cada célula cada espacio y
reconocer en nosotros toda esa vida que
está viva en nosotros todo lo que nos
está hablando dentro de nosotros a veces
es muy fácil escuchar afuera lo que se
está diciendo pero no eres capaz de
escuchar el dolor y qué está diciendo el
dolor como compartimos una salud
integral que reconozca que no somos el
centro del universo no somos el centro
del mundo pero si somos granito de arena
en ese tanto de arena que hay en el mar
por ejemplo para compartirnos todos como
granos para una mejor reciprocidad y
seguramente va a haber quien vaya a
tirar su basura al mar pero también
habrá quién quién se lo lleve entonces
cómo compartimos la salud desde desde
mirar lo que estamos haciendo nosotros y
no enfocarnos en lo que están haciendo
los demás cuando la salud es esto para
mí como recobramos proyectos
comunitarios que nos hagan estar bien
normalmente todo lo teorizó habra hits y
entonces la teoría para mí tiene que ver
con el proceso asambleario de los
pueblos originarios de oaxaca que tienen
pues un poquito más de 500 años
trabajando con esa metodología de
asamblea como como una forma resolutiva
la del que queremos los demás y a veces
no se entiende esa forma de pues de
hacer acuerdos porque todos gritamos a
la vez bueno todas muy recientemente
porque antes era asamblea solo de
hombres
y entonces es como en plena ebullición
puede haber una calma llegando a
consensos no pasando encima de nadie
pero respetando sus acuerdos eso para mí
en salud no pasará encima de los demás
es una decisión de vida también o sea
seguramente en comunidades heridas en
comunidades de mucho dolor de mucho
duelo que yo creo que son muchas
comunidades de todos los pueblos
originarios no sólo juegos acá sino del
mundo es una decisión y para que los
pueblos sigan viviendo y habitan los es
decir que yo soy zapoteca frente a que
me digan que soy indígena y no lo soy no
esté
este es como uno recobra su propio su
propia esencia y dice con esto quiero
caminar